I am research assistant Corvette I'm
gonna be straight here I had kind of a
long night last night and I threw up an
advil this morning so yeah you may be
wondering why I'm giving this
orientation that's a good question
anyways I'm here to talk to you about
properly recording things when you write
down containment procedures or
descriptions or incident reports or yeah
this is a pretty important I guess I
mean you can't write shitty reports or
else you'll be you know fired or
something okay now before we even get on
to writing stuff it's important that you
all know what to add as a picture now I
know some of these things may be scary
to photograph but I swear to God if I
see one more [ __ ] artist's depiction
I don't it's just no just put in a
picture or don't put something in at all
okay so the first part that everyone
sees after the photograph is the item
number
no I don't know how many times I've seen
some dumbass who didn't capitalize or
put in a hyphen or some [ __ ]
look okay that's just how could you
forget that honestly what could possibly
have made you forget to put in a [ __ ]
- Jesus I thought you were medically
chosen or some [ __ ] god I don't even
know how they recruit nowadays they they
like do the online thing now right yeah
okay yeah so so yeah I just remember -
okay now after that comes the object
class now I don't care how pants
shedding li terrifying the giant blob
looks if all its gonna do is make the
floor slimy it's not cater do we need to
destroy this thing no is it even going
to kill any of us
no well unless you're like old or some
[ __ ]
break your head look just try the locked
room thing I'm pretty sure you all know
it okay if it does nothing to escape the
room it's safe if you don't know what
the [ __ ] it's Euclid if it pops out eat
your grandmother who slept on the
slime-covered floor and broke her hip it
skater okay okay the next wait are you
serious that's not even like a good
ringtone and you're a junior anyways
when the [ __ ] did you get phone
permissions give me that oh look he was
texting someone else this class [ __ ]
sir
[ __ ] you buddy get out of my class no
get out Jesus Christ I didn't even want
to teach this okay can we just can we
move on please okay the containment
procedures this is the most important
part of the document because you know
people have to follow these instructions
to contain the thing that means you
can't mess up and end up having the
researchers pour orange juice on a sip
instead of potassium iodide and end up
teaching some random [ __ ] about
proper documentation and please do your
research beforehand listen people
alchemy died 200 years ago
you can't consult a practitioner of it
okay if there are any questions just
direct it to the head researcher
okay what well maybe they're blacked out
because you're all amateurs
we can't trust a deal with a high
clearance if I had next up we have the
description this is pretty
straightforward just please be clinical
okay the SIP skin is not Hale as the
moonlight in color okay
it's [ __ ] white understand and don't
just insert expungement willy-nilly I
understand sometimes it's been a long
day and it's just easier to insert or
add acted here and there until tomorrow
but when I'm looking at a document and I
see scp-432 one is a humanoid that data
expunged it's just it's not fun for
anyone as for the experiment log you're
free to do anything to please for the
love of God be clear in your recording
I'm sure you're all aware of a certain
incident involving sharks and I don't
want to see anything like that again
just promise me you won't do that please
I think that about ends this lecture
you're all free to go
Oh before you leave if I see any of you
making hilarious comments at the end of
reports I will find you I don't invent
cator duty just for you that's about it
yeah anyone have a [ __ ] Tylenol
you